The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're now
at storyboard 23.
Let's look at panel
A. Our last metabolism
topic under the general umbrella
of catabolism is ketone bodies.
Ketone bodies are only covered
in two pages in the book,
but they're medically
very important.
The medical relevance
of ketone bodies
stems from their
role in starvation
and their role in diabetes.
Let's look at panel A. This
panel shows various sources of
and uses of acetyl CoA.
It shows that ketone bodies are
made from Acetyl coenzyme A.
So let's start this
part of the lecture
with a discussion of where
acetyl CoA comes from,
and what its various
states are including
the formation of ketone bodies.
We just finished talking
about fatty acid catabolism.
So let's start on the
right of this figure.
We see that a fatty
acid can be broken down
to form acetyl CoA
by beta oxidation,
usually with the objective
of generating energy.
If we follow the acetyl
CoA from beta oxidation
down into the TCA
cycle, we see that it
will be fully oxidized to carbon
dioxide with the generation
of a lot of energy
that can be used
for mechanical work,
biosynthesis, and other things.
A second source
of Acetyl CoA can
be seen to the
left, where we see
glycogen breakdown
to glucose or glucose
can be directly
imported into a cell.
In either case, the glucose
that we take in or liberate
from its storage
depot, glycogen,
can be converted into
acetyl coenzyme A.
Glycerol can be generated
from the backbone
of a metabolized
triacylglyceride.
It enters glycolysis as
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and then can progress to acetyl
CoA by way of glycolysis.
Alanine can transiminate
into pyruvate,
which is converted
subsequently to acetyl CoA
by pyruvate dehydrogenase.
This diagram shows us that
many pathways converge
to generate acetyl coenzyme
A. Carbohydrates, amino acids,
fatty acids, all
can act as a source
of this important
precursor to energy.
Aside from being processed by
the TCA cycle, on the left,
we see a broken line
pathway involving
fatty acid biosynthesis.
This is going to be the
next topic we come to
after this discussion of
ketone body formation.
The pathway on the right
with the broken lines
is the pathway leading
to ketone bodies
which is called ketogenesis.
In the box at the top of panel
A is a cartoon reminding me
to tell you that acetyl CoA
cannot escape from the cell.
Moreover, it cannot even easily
escape from the mitochondrion.
In order for acetyl
CoA to leave the cell
and be transported from
one organ to another,
it needs to be converted
into ketone bodies.
Another way to look
at ketone bodies
is that these are
mobile or portable forms
of Acetyl CoA that can go from
a source organ, which is usually
the liver, to a target organ,
which may need them in order
to generate energy by
way of the TCA cycle.
The target organ for
example could be brain
under conditions of
starvation, or it
could be skeletal
muscle if you have
to run away from something.
Let's look at panel B. There
are five key facts that we need
to know about ketone bodies.
First, Ketogenesis mainly
occurs in the liver.
The liver manufactures
ketone bodies
and then exports them
to other organs for use.
These reactions typically happen
when the levels of oxaloacetate
become limiting in
their mitochondrion.
And I'll give you
an example of why
this is the case when I talk
about starvation a little later
in this lecture.
The second important
fact is that these
are the primary metabolic
fuels of the heart and skeletal
muscle under normal conditions.
The third fact is
that ketone bodies
become the major metabolic
fuel of all cells
under conditions
of starvation, even
cells of the brain after
a few days of starvation
will convert from glucose being
the preferred metabolic fuel
to accepting ketone bodies as
their major source of energy.
The fourth fact I want
to talk about with regard
to ketone bodies
is that they are
produced in excess in diabetes.
I'll talk a little
bit more about that
later in the lecture.
Finally, ketogenesis occurs in
the mitochondrion, primarily
the mitochondrion of the liver.
So these are
mitochondrial reactions.
Panel C shows the three
classical ketone bodies,
acetoacetate, beta
hydroxybutyrate, and acetone.
From the standpoint
of chemical accuracy,
it's obvious that
beta hydroxybutyrate
is an alcohol and not a ketone.
Nevertheless, it's lumped
in with the ketone bodies
for historical reasons.
Acetoacetate and
beta hydroxybutyrate
are what I'll call quote
unquote "useful" ketone
bodies from the standpoint
of serving as precursors
to metabolic energy.
Acetone by contrast, is not
useful by this criterion.
Acetone however, is
a useful biomarker,
because sometimes its presence
can help diagnose diabetes.
On a personal note, I come
from a long line of diabetics.
I remember when I was a
little kid, my dad before he
was diagnosed, would
come home from work
at the end of the day.
He had very poor circulation.
So my two sisters
and I would try
to rub his legs to give
him a kind of massage
to make his circulation
a little bit better.
I remember very clearly my
older sister saying, "gee,
dad smells like mom's
nail polish remover,"
and that's because he
was a diabetic producing
acetone, which was used
at the time at least
as nail polish remover.
We had no idea at the
time what was going on.
A few months later, my dad was
diagnosed as a type 2 diabetic.
I now know that the fruity
odor we smelled on his breath
was acetone.
As I said, acetone is a
biomarker of this disease.
One last point with
regard to the story board.
Note that the acetoacetate and
beta hydroxybutyrate molecules
are acids.
In diabetics, these
acids can be produced
as we'll see later
in sufficiently
high concentrations to
lower the pH of the blood
quite substantially.
Keep in mind that
lowering the pH
is the same thing as increasing
the concentration of protons
in the blood.
These concentrated protons will
have physiological relevance
that I'll discuss later.
When a diabetic enters the phase
where the pH of their blood
is dangerously low, that's
called diabetic acidosis.
Let's now turn to
Panel D. At this point
I want to describe the detailed
biochemical reactions that
give rise to ketone bodies.
To make a ketone
body we're going
to need three molecules
of acetyl coenzyme
A. One of these molecules
is going to be catalytic.
That is, it's going to be
restored at the overall end
of the process of ketogenesis.
Let's start by
imagining a scenario
in the mitochondrion
of a liver cell
where oxaloacetate
becomes limiting.
I'll talk about physiological
states under which oxaloacetate
becomes limiting or
sparse a little bit later.
Acetyl CoA cannot
enter the TCA cycle,
because citrate synthase lacks
oxaloacetate as a reaction
partner.
The concentration of acetyl
CoA starts to accumulate.
Then the beta
ketothiolase reaction
that is the last step in
fatty acid bio oxidation
reverses owing to the high
concentration of product acetyl
CoA.
So two acetyl CoAs
come together in order
to form acetoacetyl
coenzyme A. Note
that I put markers on
each of the carbons
of the acetoacetyl coenzyme A.
A third acetoacetyl coenzyme
A is then added to
the gamma carbon
of the acetoacetyl coenzyme
A. That's the carbon that
has the filled-in square.
The enzyme that catalyzed
this last reaction
is HMG Coenzyme A
reductase, where HMG stands
for hydroxymethylglutaryl.
HMG CoA is a six-carbon
branch chain molecule.
In the present
situation, we're going
to look at HMG CoA as the
source of ketone bodies
in the mitochondrion,
but I want you
to keep in mind that
if this reaction were
to occur not in
the mitochondrion
but in the cytoplasm, the
resulting HMG CoA could
be used for other pathways.
For example, HMG
CoA in the cytosol
is the precursor to cholesterol.
With that in mind, let's
return our attention
to the mitochondrion
and ketogenesis.
The mitochondrial
enzyme HMG CoA lyase
will split the HMG
CoA, knocking off
an acetyl CoA in liberating
as the final product
acetoacetate, which is our
first of three ketone bodies.
Acetoacetate is a beta
keto acid and hence,
prone to spontaneous
decarboxylation.
Non enzymatically, this will
happen at some slow rate
in order to liberate CO2
and produce acetone, which
is our second ketone body.
This acetone gives
the fruity smell
to the breath of a diabetic
whose disease is out
of control.
Acetone is not going to be
biochemically useful to us,
for example it's not going to be
metabolized to generate energy.
The second chemical
fate of the acetoacetate
is its reduction by NADH using
the enzyme beta hydroxybutyrate
dehydrogenase.
This reduction forms our
third ketone body beta
hydroxybutyrate, which is a
biochemically useful molecule
in that it serves as
a good metabolic fuel.
Acetoacetate and
beta hydroxybutyrate
do not need any kind
of special transporter
to get out of the
cell into the blood.
They diffuse through the
mitochondrial membrane
and later through
the cell membrane.
They are then transported
by the circulatory system
from the liver to organs
that need them for energy.
As you mentioned
above, ketone bodies
are portable forms
of acetyl CoA.
In a real sense, the liver
by making these ketone bodies
is acting as a
food caterer where
ketone bodies
represent food that's
delivered to other organs.
At this point let's
look at storyboard 24
panel A. Now let's
take a look what
happens when the ketone
bodies travel by the blood
and are taken up by another
organ such as muscle.
Acetoacetate, which I'll
refer to as ketone body
one is good to go
and is ready to enter
the main stream of metabolism.
So I'm going to come
back to it in a minute.
The beta hydroxybutyrate,
by contrast,
has to be processed
in order for it
to be useful to the target organ
skeletal muscle in this case.
In step two, the muscle
form of beta hydroxybutyrate
dehydrogenase will use
NAD plus to oxidize
the beta hydroxybutyrate
into acetoacetate, which
joins the pool of acetoacetate
that came in directly
from the blood.
We now have to put a thioester
group on the acetoacetate,
and that comes from
an unusual source.
In step three you'll see
a succinyl coenzyme A
from the TCA cycle
giving its coenzyme
A residue to acetoacetate,
which results
in the formation of
acetoacetyl coenzyme A.
This reaction happens in the
mitochondrion of the cell.
At step four acetyl
coenzyme A is
converted by beta ketothiolase
into two molecules
of acetyl coenzyme
A. And again, we're
going to need another
coenzyme A group
to come in at this point as
part of the beta ketothiolase
reaction.
Remember that beta
ketothiolase is
the last enzyme that's
operative in beta oxidation
of fatty acids.
Here it's doing
the same chemistry
that it does in beta oxidation.
It splits acetoacetyl CoA
into two acetyl CoA molecules.
And in steps five and
six, those molecules
integrate into the TCA cycle.
In the TCA cycle they're
oxidized to carbon dioxide
with the generation of energy.
Let me review for a
minute before going
into a physiological scenario.
Way over to the
left at step one,
the liver has made acetyl
CoA and packaged it
into two ketone
bodies, acetoacetate
and beta hydroxybutyrate.
They travel in the
blood to target tissues,
for example, the muscle,
or heart, or the brain.
In these target tissues these
ketone bodies are internalized,
converted to acetoacetate, and
then to acetoacetyl coenzyme A
and then ultimately to several
molecules of acetyl coenzyme A.
The acetyl coenzyme A
that started in the liver,
ends up in the target
tissue and then can
be used to generate energy.
This is a particularly important
reaction under conditions
of starvation and diabetes.
Let's now look at panel
b of storyboard 24.
As you know, I like to look
at physiological scenarios
because at least to me, they
helped make biochemistry real.
The scenario I want to look
at is that of diabetes.
In Type 2 diabetes, which
is the type that I have,
my cells have become resistant
to taking up glucose.
My cells are
insulin insensitive.
After a meal I have very,
very high concentrations
of glucose in my blood,
because the cells of my tissues
are not capable of taking it in.
Hence, if I do not take my
anti-diabetic medication
the sugar concentration
in my blood
stays high, which leads to some
of the medical complications
of diabetes.
More on that later.
Given that there's a lot
of glucose in my blood,
but it's not getting
into my cells,
my cells are actually in a
technical state of starvation.
Take a look at the pathway
I've drawn in panel b.
Glucose on the left is
not getting into the cell.
I've used broken lines for
the pathway from glucose
to pyruvate and then from
pyruvate in the cytoplasm
into the mitochondrial matrix.
These broken lines
are meant to indicate
that the pathways involved
are just not very active.
The sparse activity
of these pathways
means that acetyl CoA
levels are becoming somewhat
limiting in the mitochondrion.
Because pyruvate
is also limiting,
the enzyme pyruvate
carboxylase doesn't
have sufficient
pyruvate in order
to maintain the
oxaloacetate concentration
within the mitochondrial matrix.
Once again, oxaloacetate is
the TCA cycle intermediate
that that's at the lowest, that
is micromolar concentration.
I'm focusing here on
the liver, although I
should add at this point
that all tissues are
similarly limited in
the pathways indicated
by the broken lines.
The liver's response to
sensing this limitation
in carbohydrate processing
is to either take in lipid
or to break it down
from internal stores,
for example, triacylglycerides
in order to produce acetyl CoA.
But because oxaloacetate
is limiting,
the step at beta
ketothiolase backs up,
producing a large
amount of ketone bodies.
The ketone bodies are
produced in excess,
so you can see them escaping
into the mitochondrion
and later out of the cell, and
they go off into the blood.
Consequently, the
liver of diabetics
produces a lot of ketone
bodies, because it senses
that the body is starving,
To the right of panel B, I have
some blood chemistry values
that are of relevance
to diabetics.
In a non-diabetic person,
blood sugar concentrations,
that is blood
glucose is maintained
at about 100
milligrams of glucose
per 100 milliliters of blood.
When I was diagnosed
with diabetes,
my blood sugar was over 300
milligrams per 100 milliliters.
As I recall the symptoms
were disorientation.
I couldn't walk very
easily, I was thirsty,
and I urinated a lot.
Normal ketone body
concentrations
are less than 0.2 nanomolar.
In a severe diabetic situation,
your ketone body concentrations
could be 15 to 25 millimolar
and the pH of your blood
could drop from the mid 7
range down to about 6.8.
The kidney responds to the
high concentration of glucose
and the high
concentration of protons,
that is the low pH, by
increasing urine volume output
in order to try to urinate
out the glucose and protons.
The results are that the
diabetic becomes excessively
thirsty which again is
one of the biomarkers
or symptoms of the disease.
The classic historical
treatment of diabetes
is to give insulin, which will
push more glucose into the cell
and thus offset the biochemical
defect that leads ultimately
to ketone bodies and to the
high concentration of glucose
in the blood.
Aside from giving
insulin by injection
there are other
medications that will
result in a sort of
reactivation of the beta cells
in the pancreas in order to
produce more insulin naturally.
Alternatively, there
are medications
that will block
gluconeogenesis and thus
stop the ability of the liver
and other gluconeogenic organs
from producing glucose.
So by blocking
gluconeogenesis, one
can lower the glucose
concentration of the blood.
As you see there are many, many
ways to treat this disease.
Let me add that it can be a very
debilitating disease, leading
to blindness, amputation, and
cardiovascular difficulties.
It's a good idea to
try to avoid the risk
factors for this disease.
It's not fully
preventable at least
in people who come from families
in which nearly everybody gets
it, for example, my situation.
But by avoiding risk factors you
can push off the date of onset
by many years.